le fait d'être une star ça vous a amené
à faire des rencontres amoureuses ou
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde a parlé vous êtes né le 3
septembre 1963 au Mans père représentant
de commerce mère femme au foyer et vous
commencez à pratiquer la natation
sportive à jouer les tours région
banlieue de Tours en plus vous prenez
des cours de danse car à l'époque vous
rêviez d'être petit rat de l'opéra c'est
vrai mais comme vous mesurez un mètre 55
à l'âge de 9 ans évidemment c'est un peu
compromis pour la danse quoi
il y avait
à l'Opéra de Paris mon rêve moi c'était
d'être danseuse à l'Opéra donc très
rapidement mon professeur de danse m'a
dit Muriel faut oublier mais fait de la
danse pour ton plaisir quand même alors
à 12 ans vous découvrez la natation
synchronisée voilà c'est une révélation
vous dites je pouvais enfin conjuguer
mes deux passions l'eau et la danse
c'était un rêve d'enfant qui se
dessinait sous mes yeux j'ai trouvé ça
merveilleux timide à l'époque l'eau est
une est une barrière pour vous
c'est-à-dire vous vous retranchez du
reste du monde quand vous êtes dans
l'eau oui parce que quand vous êtes au
milieu d'un bassin et que vous avez 20
mètres entre le bord et vous et
forcément personne ne venait me chercher
au milieu du bassin comme on entraîneur
criait un peu trop fort et que où j'en
avais marre à ce moment là je me mettais
assez de sous l'eau j'allais au fond
j'ai fait tranquille c'était serein
enfin c'est à 14 ans vous entrez en
équipe de France de natation
synchronisée dès lors les performances
vont s'accumuler ce qui fait que votre
vie là va complètement se centrer autour
du sport oui oui dans la mesure où le
sport était une je ne me levais que dans
l'espoir d'aller m'entraîner à la
piscine je travaillais de moins en moins
à l'école passer beaucoup de temps au
fond du bassin ce qui fait que le sport
est devenu ma vie et mon espérancement
mon moyen de me réaliser vous entraîner
7 heures par jour vous sortez peu je
sortais pas du tout moi ah oui
non non c'est un choix dans la mesure où
une passion rien n'est un poids vous le
vivez pleinement vous l'assumez il y a
des choix à faire dans la vie forcément
quand on prend une direction une autre à
l'époque quand vous entraînez pas vous
dites bon ça il y a plus d'entraînements
c'est cool mais en fait au bout d'un
moment ça vous manque à nouveau
l'entraînement donc vous avez envie d'y
retourner des sportifs c'est que plus
vous entraînez et plus le corps demande
cette activité là
alors résultat vous êtes 12 fois
championne de France 4 fois championne
d'Europe mais la grande joie de votre
carrière sportive ce sera les
championnats d'Europe de Strasbourg en
1987 là c'est l'état de grâce parce que
vous atteignez un équilibre presque
parfait entre l'effort et le plaisir
toute ma vie je pensais que mes limites
seraient physique et à cette compétition
là j'ai compris qu'elle n'était pas
physique mais qu'elles étaient
psychologiques c'est-à-dire toute ma vie
à chaque fois que je gagnais une
médaille je me dis mais
tant d'effort pour cet instant qui
passait vite et puis cette médaille qui
devine breloque au bout d'un mois que
vous posez sur un meuble et puis qui ne
représente plus rien
c'est ça qui m'a motivé toute ma vie à
continuer l'entraînement et à cette
compétition là l'émotion que j'ai
ressentie a été tellement forte qu'elle
a gommé tous ce sentiment
d'insatisfaction et là j'ai compris que
j'avais à ta mal aimé psychologique
psychologique forte de ce sentiment
d'accomplissement vous décidez d'arrêter
pas encore les Jeux olympiques de Séoul
en 88 et c'est un peu l'année de trop là
je me disais toujours à quel moment
j'arrêterai ma carrière on rêve tous
d'arrêter sur un succès sur quelque
chose de grandiose et c'était 87
Strasbourg mais arrêtez à un an des Jeux
alors qu'il y a vous êtes troisième
mondial et que vous avez ramené une
chance de podium la pression médiatique
de ma famille de la fédé a fait que je
n'ai pas osé dire non vous y allez vous
entraîner d'abord 7 heures par jour
pendant un an ensuite vous y allez et
vous loupez le podium de 2 centièmes sur
un total de 200 je l'ai raté deux
sorties mais c'est de ma faute parce que
dans ma tête je n'ai pas cru à la
victoire c'est à ce niveau-là de
compétition c'est fondamental faut pas
douter alors à partir de là l'idée qui
nous occupe désormais c'est la création
de grands spectacles aquatiques mais
rien n'existe dans ce domaine en fait
alors j'ai du mal à convaincre vous
allez voir des des producteurs des Camus
des coulis vous leur expliquer votre
truc ils disent oui c'est une bonne idée
mais voilà et puis si ça marche vous
venez nous voir un peu facile
alors c'est Yannick votre mari qui vous
aidera et puis aussi EDF
Marie-France Brière Alain degrès qui
vont vous permettre de monter Cirella en
octobre 91 au Zénith de Paris c'est
énormément de succès c'était colossal 80
000 spectateurs en 8 jours de
représentation et puis ça faisait
longtemps que je disais dans la presse
que après la carrière sportive je
montrais un grand spectacle qui se
déroulerait pas dans une piscine mais
dans une salle de spectacle et là
c'était la réalisation d'un grand rêve
attendu parce que j'avais réussi à
susciter l'attente du public qui fait
que quand il a ouvert ils sont tous
venus ça existait un peu à l'étranger
non pas du tout parce qu'entre la fin
des Jeux olympiques de Séoul et 91 je
suis allé à Vegas à New York sur
Broadway Atlanta également voir un peu
ce qui se passait dans le monde du
spectacle aquatique et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait rien
grand succès jusqu'au Japon il y avait
combien de semi-remorque on avait deux
sens
construisait un bassin olympique qu'un
immense bassin qu'on installé dans des
dans des stades des stadiums version
japonaises c'est-à-dire il y avait 15000
spectateurs ont construisait les décors
les mais c'était complètement fou
c'était des productions gigantesques
c'était vraiment des rêves on peut dire
que l'artiste supplante la sportive à ce
moment là quoi oui ben disons que
l'artiste a éteint la sportive c'était
une première reconversion quelque part
la mort de la sportive a donné naissance
à l'artiste mais la grande force de la
natation synchronisée c'est que vous
développez à la fois la part artistique
et la part sportive donc pour moi
c'était simplement une prolongation oui
une prolongation suite à un voyage en
Afrique avec votre mari vous écrivez un
nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle
crescendo et c'est la rencontre entre le
monde de l'eau et celui du oui très
nouveau ça aussi il était lancé au
Cirque d'Hiver Bouglione où on a
réhabilité la piscine qui avait été
inauguré par mistinguette en 1933 et là
je mettais des chevaux qui qui
évoluaient au milieu des nageuses et
nageuses qui passaient autour d'eux des
trapèzes qui montaient de l'eau les une
patinoire avec des plongeurs enfin
c'était c'était
ce spectacle va chez Disney c'est la
première fois que Disney donnait un
spectacle qui n'avait pas été inventé
par eux tout à fait alors là on peut
dire que le metteur en scène supplante
l'artiste quoi c'est un choix c'est un
phénix alors à l'époque vous êtes quand
même une star importante en France vous
avez vécu ça comment
bien parce que grâce au sport j'ai
compris que la notoriété
était très éphémère et que vous pouviez
monter très vite et redescendre très
vite et pour moi la seule chose qui
compte c'est ce qu'on fait sur le
terrain c'est le travail c'est le
quotidien c'est la persévérance dans ses
choix et je sais à quel point pour
réussir dans un domaine il faut
travailler donc forcément ça vous ramène
toujours à en fait vous savez ce que
vous avez investi pour en arriver là
quoi absolument et avec les médias ça
s'est passé comment bien toujours des
très bonnes relations
j'ai gagné de l'argent et d'autres fois
j'en ai perdu question amour le fait
d'être une star ça vous a amené à faire
des rencontres amoureuses ou
non non parce que mon mari est venu
après ma carrière sportive ou dans le
sport si vous mettez beaucoup de place à
l'amour et il reste plus beaucoup de
place pour la performance
elle en est un bel exemple ce qui fait
qu'il est arrivé au moment où justement
j'arrêtais avant de monter les
spectacles on les a montés ensemble ils
travaillent avec moi donc forcément ça
s'est bien goupillé
pas de place pour un autre quel était le
meilleur moment de toute cette époque
c'est Strasbourg lorsque je suis montée
sur le podium et qu'on m'a remis la
médaille
bien sûr le drapeau est monté on a
envoyé la Marseillaise et un moment
donné la bande son dans dans le système
d'enregistrement s'est arrêté elle s'est
cassée le public était debout il y a eu
un flottement un an j'ai passé et à ce
moment là le public a repris la
Marseillaise et me l'a offert et je peux
vous dire que c'est une émotion du lait
quelle intensité
mais là c'était le summum c'était que
j'appelle moi l'état de grâce ce moment
tout d'un coup tout vous revient tout a
un sens et tout prend une justesse par
rapport à ce que vous avez pu donner et
le pire moment de toute cette époque
c'est où c'est forcément de mettre du
compte que j'étais passé si proche du
podium parce que je n'ai pas cru
c'est rien du tout et là ça a été
vraiment très difficile et là j'ai
compris que quitte à faire autant faire
bien jusqu'au bout et auto y croire
jusqu'au bout alors en mars 2003 faites
un nouveau spectacle s'appelle freedom
qui ouvre au Cirque d'hiver alors c'est
un spectacle autour du gospel qui traite
de l'esclavagisme du métissage du
racisme alors il y a un problème bon il
y a pas d'eau l'armurier l'hermine sans
eau les gens comprennent pas bien et
puis aussi la communauté noire estime
que c'est pas une blanche de de
s'occuper de leur histoire
ça c'était un c'était très difficile
non il a relativement marché il a quand
même fermé un mois et demi avant donc
après en fait vous n'avez plus remonter
de grands spectacles comme ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque de Cirella des grands
spectacles comme ça non
non c'est plein de le travail que je
fais avec l'association que j'ai monté
qui s'appelle j'ai un rêve d'accompagner
dans les quartiers défavorisés des
enfants en échec scolaire et difficultés
familiales je veux dire j'aurais mis
j'aurais donné 10 ans de céréales pour
vivre une année de travail là si c'était
à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil dans votre vie je
ne à des choses que je sentirais
finalement utopique
toujours su écouter
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez qu'on écrive
sur votre tombe à bientôt je reviens
et merci Muriel c'est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu